hi I'm Evan Carmichael and today I have
a special video for you in collaboration
with Success expert and best-selling
author Brian Tracy today I'm going to
talk about the five characteristics that
set successful entrepreneurs apart once
you're done watching this video make
sure to head over to Brian's channel to
find out his take on the five success
characteristics that every entrepreneur
needs to have the link to his channel
will be in the description below the
first trait of all successful
entrepreneurs is that they are
self-aware they know who they are they
know what they stand for they know what
they want to accomplish they have a very
strong sense of self I believe that
every person has one word that defines
them that is their core value that they
can build their business around for me
it's belief so all of my videos my
business the content I create is all
about belief
I strongly encourage entrepreneurs to
find out what they stand for and use
that as the lens to make your decisions
once you know who you are and what you
stand for it's way easier to make every
single business decision that you need
to make from hiring to product selection
to raising capital everything becomes
easier once you know who you are and
what you stand for
the second trait of successful
entrepreneurs is that they followed
their passion if you look at successful
famous entrepreneurs the most common
piece of advice that you hear over and
over and over and over again is that
they followed their passion passion
passion passion passion passion passion
I should because starting the business
is hard and it's one of the hardest
things that you will ever do in your
life and you need to go through an
insane number of trials and tribulations
running the business will test you and
push you so hard and the only thing that
keeps you going when everybody around
you might be telling you to quit with a
logical safe smart thing to do to quit
the only thing that keeps you going is
the passion that you have for what you
do you have to be crazy and love with
the product or service that you're
creating and if you're not to continue
to explore until you find the thing that
makes you come alive
the third trade is that successful
entrepreneurs see failure as feedback
people who are afraid of failure people
who see failure as permanent and that
they cannot achieve success after the
first failure they never become
successful entrepreneurs the successful
entrepreneurs are the people who
understand that you will fail your way
to success you will fail fail fail fail
fail and then you'll succeed and if you
look at every successful entrepreneur
and you look at how they started they
made a number of critical failures but
they didn't let that stop them they
didn't let that be terminal they didn't
let that be the end of their business
they kept going through those failures
the key is to learn from every failure
if you've learned from the failure then
it's not a failure the only failure is
in not learning from your mistakes
the fourth trait is to model success
understand that whatever problem you're
going through right now someone has
already solved it from acquiring
customers to bring it on partners to get
it into the media to build successful
products whatever it is it's already
been solved by people and the
entrepreneurs who just try to cope with
every single new idea themselves they
often struggle to be successful where
the really successful ones are the ones
who understand that I can model the
success of others that success leaves
clues that by finding out how Bill Gates
became such a successful entrepreneur or
modeling Brian Tracy or modeling Steve
Jobs or modeling people who have already
achieved a lot of success that leaves
clues for you to be able to leave your
own mark on the world and so successful
entrepreneurs are the ones who model
success that has come before them and
then build upon it
and the fifth trait is to create a great
environment it's really hard to do great
things when you are not surrounded by
greatness everything from your habits to
your routine to what's on the wall to
the need that you listen to to the
people that you surround yourself with
your environment either holds you where
you are or encourages you to grow and to
be something amazing and so you have
control over that too many people are
very reactionary and just fall into
their daily routine by accident where if
you plan for greatness if you surround
yourself with greatness every single day
you create that great environment then
you're much more likely to do great
things so those are my top five traits
that every successful entrepreneur must
have I'd encourage you to check out
brian tracy best-selling author and
success expert he made a video on his
channel talking about the same topic
that I'll link up in the description
below and right here on the video now
I'm curious to hear from you what do you
think are the traits that every
successful entrepreneur must have leave
it in the comments below and I'm gonna
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon